[Music]  now the starting lineup for your LA  Clippers at one guard six was in his  eighth year from the city of Chicago  number 21 Patrick Beverley Edgard 65 in  his second season from Wichita State  number 20  Landry 7 the man is a middle seven-foot  in his fist and pay from Croatia number  40  alveta zu ba head one four six nine in  his 10th season from Kentucky number 54  Patrick Utterson and it forward six  seven in his ninth year from San Diego  State number T Cole  ladies and gentlemen your hey flippers  [Music]  ladies and gentlemen now won't you  please make noise for Clippers forward  Kawhi Leonard hey welcome clipper fans  to the game tonight it's going to be a  great season we won't we gonna work hard  every night and let's get it going  he is